Cancer cells are not only like pathogens
in that they can evade and suppress the
immune system.
They're also white pathogens in
that they rapidly evolve resistance.
That is a serious problem
for cancer therapy,
so we will now discuss how to manage
the evolve resistance of cancer cells.
Okay.
Chemotherapy selects for rapid
evolution of resistant clones.
This is the same principle that we
saw with the evolution of antibiotic
resistance in bacteria.
Strong selection is producing
a rapid resistance response.
There are some alternatives to chemo
chemotherapy that are being explored.
There's targeted immunotherapy,
there is adaptive therapy where
the motto is Pharma don't know it,
and then there is targeting public goods,
so the same range of options that we
can think of in trying to control.
The evolution of antibiotic resistance
is also being examined for controlling
the resistance that
evolves with chemotherapy.
It's pretty hard to kill the
cancer without killing the patient.
After all the sales that were trying
to kill our cells that are very closely
related to the healthy cells in
the patient, they're human cells.
The more drug we use, the stronger the
effect is. That's the dose response curve.
Usually there's a phase one clinical
trial to see what the tolerable dose might
be.
Then there's a phase two clinical trial
that gives evidence that the treatment
is effective and then there's a phase
three clinical trial which is randomized
and placebo controlled,
uh, and it's expensive.
So normally by the time a drug has
proceeded through these three different
levels of trial,
success at the end is defined now as
extending the life by an average of a few
months.
So it's a frustrating situation.
We aren't really helping the
patients as much as we would like to.
Yeah.
Here's the typical clinical
experience for a patient with cancer.
Patient arrives in the clinic
with the late stage cancer.
That means it has already metastasized.
It's throughout the body.
Surgery is therefore considered
ineffective. Not all of them.
Metasticies could be found.
A cytotoxic chemotherapy is started.
Usually it's once a week for three weeks.
It attacks all of the
proliferating cells in the body.
The patient's hair falls out,
the gut lining sloughs off,
the tumor,
shrinks or even disappears
from an Mri or an X. Ray.
However, please note, a mass of a
million cells is not visible on an MRI.
So there could be a lot of metastasis in
the body of the patient and they would
be invisible after chemotherapy.
A few months later,
the tumor reappears APP application
of the same drug has no effect.
So the doctors tried different drug
and that's exactly how we would select
resistance in the lab if we were trying
to select resistance to the sell wine or
a bacterial culture.
So the standard way of using chemotherapy
is the most effective way to rapidly
select resistance.
Yeah,
there are different kinds of chemotherapy.
There are cytotoxins that kill cells.
So five f you have blocks.
DNA synthesis is plat and buys the DNA
and causes problems that trigger a pop
ptosis. They both kill cells. There
are targeted therapies like Gleevec.
It fits into the brick abl cancer genes.
So that's a breast cancer gene.
Tamoxifen blocks the estrogen receptors.
So for the estrogen sensitive,
uh,
breast cancer's Tomoxifin is used.
You're fit an,
it blocks the epithelial
growth factor receptor.
Yeah.
These therapies have been shown to select
for cells with resistance mutations.
Gleevec resistance comes
from point mutations in the
pocket where Gleevec vines
to brick abl or doing its amplification.
And the mutation is often
present before therapy.
So it's in that diverse genetically
heterogeneous set of clones
get fit.
A nub resistance is in a
mutation to Egf are five,
four years or so.
Resistance is in mutations and extra
copies of t y m s and the result is the
treatment fails especially it feels,
especially in smokers and in
people with late stage tumors.
Now what about targeted immunotherapy?
The immune system can be
used to target cancer cells.
It stimulates cytotoxic t cells and it
suppresses the immunosuppressive cells
that increase up to 10 fold
in cancer patients. So there,
so this is the enemy of
my enemy is my friend.
There have been some dramatic successes
and some disappointing failures with
extremely, very lung cancers including
ovarian cancer and melanomas.
In some cases with Melanomas,
targeted immunotherapy has cleared
the cancer out of the body,
the patient completely and others
it hasn't worked and it's uh,
it's about a 50% success rate.
There are multiple immune pathways in
the tumor microenvironment that are both
inhibitory and costimulatory and
they can be targets of therapeutic
manipulation. So when
this diagram, but the,
the pathways are indicated here
by the arrows. Here is the tumor,
here is an cell or a macrophage.
Here is the t regulatory cell,
here is a tumor specific cytotoxic cell.
Okay.
So it's a cytotoxic t lymphocyte.
The MDS sees those are myeloid
immunosuppressive cells that increase that
increase up to tenfold in
the cancer patients. So
these need to be suppressed to allow
there to be effective antitumor activity
from,
okay,
the cytotoxic t cells and the particular
approaches that seem most promising are
those that block these inhibitory
receptors here on the t reg cells.
So this particular receptor here
and this particular receptor here,
PD one and Ctla four,
there are also evolutionary
approaches. We can, we could use,
for example, drug cocktails that require
different mechanisms for resistance,
where each drug is targeting a different
resistance mechanism that makes the,
uh, evolution of resistance
highly improbable. However,
the combined side effects of multiple
components of a cocktail could be
unsupportable or even fatal.
So even one chemotherapeutic drug often
is causing extreme discomfort to the
patient and two, three or four of them
together could actually kill the patient.
Okay.
Secondly,
there's adaptive therapy,
which uses lower doses to control cancer
growth while slowing the evolution of
resistance.
We've seen a similar idea
with a anti microbial therapy.
Yeah.
And then it's also possible to target
public goods to disrupt cooperation within
a tumor because tumor cells actually
cooperate with each other in a way that's
rather like the social life of bacteria.
Yeah.
So here are a couple of replicates of
the same experiment in which adaptive
therapy was tried in mice.
And so in both of these,
the standard treatment,
which is in red results in just as heavy
a tumor burden is no treatment at all,
but with some delay. So no treatment at
all is the control. That's the black,
the standard therapy,
which is a strong dose,
causes the evolution of
resistance and with some delay,
the tumor burden then rises up to the
same level is if there were no therapy at
all, but adaptive therapy, which
is in green and the two replicates,
keeps the tumor burden low.
It doesn't wipe it out,
but it keeps it low and that could
extend life and reduce suffering.
It won't eliminate the cancer,
but it could buy time for the patient.
The final option is the
target public goods.
We saw that as one of the options being
pursued with antimicrobial therapy.
Yeah.
Cancer cells produce growth factors
that suppress the immune system and that
stimulate angiogenesis.
They are public goods.
A cell that did not produce those
growth factors could grow faster,
so it could be a cheater.
Growth factors are a public good and
cells that produce them are susceptible to
invasion by cells that
do not produce them.
So the therapy would be to
remove cells from the tumor,
knock out the genes for the
growth factor and then reinserted,
actually put the modified cancer cells
back into the patient to compete in the
colon competition with the ones that
are producing the growth factors.
So they have everything that made that
a good clone except the growth factors.
The modified cells then
spread the concentration of
growth factors falls and the
tumor collapses.
For lack of communication.
Evolving countermeasure
is quite difficult.
Anytime there is a mutation
in a public good gene.
So there have been tested this idea in
cell culture and then they have been
promising, but tests that in
Vivo have not yet been done.
So to summarize,
resistance to chemotherapy,
just like resistance to
antibiotics evolves rapidly.
Life lifespan in cancer patients could
be extended with alternative therapies.
Immunotherapy shows a lot of promise.
It's not cheap and that has
implications for health policy.
Immunotherapies is rather expensive,
but it has been effective in some
previously untreatable cancers.
Adaptive therapy does work in mice
and in is now being tested in clinical
trials. So we can see in the
coming years where that goes.
Targeting public goods, such as
growth factors, shows promise,
but it does need additional tests.
It's a good idea.
But at this point is preliminary.